labour's shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy joins me now from salford
listen andy good morning um
same question i asked the home secretary
what will your memories of david amos be
well i first met david when i was a
newly elected mp just over a decade ago
in fact i think he was one of the first
people that i met
in parliament and it was a fairly
awkward
moment because i've been asked if i
would stand to be an officer of an
all-party parliamentary group that was
looking at children in care and i'd gone
along to this meeting to put my name
forward only to discover that david was
currently the office holder of that post
and hadn't
resigned or stood down or indicated that
he wanted to do so so we had this little
awkward moment where he said well that's
my job and i said oh i thought it was
my job and he um he anyway he responded
with typical good grace and good nature
i think in the end we shared the
position
and worked together on upholding the
rights of children in care and that was
very very david i think the word that's
come up over and over again from
colleagues on all parts of the political
spectrum are he was just such a nice man
and he was he was courteous he was nice
he had a great sense of humor he wanted
to get the job done and he was willing
to work with whoever it took in order to
do that with great manners great sense
of fun great energy as well and he will
be really really missed by all of us
do you think i've just been talking to
him secretary about this do you think
that there is a danger now that
the link between the member of
parliament and the constituency
will be placed in danger by these events
because
we now have to think much more i guess
about
the safety of people like yourself
i think my bigger fear is that this just
keeps happening and we keep having this
debate and then nothing very much
changes the speaker of the house commons
lindsey hoyle and john burko before him
have made big efforts to try to step up
support and security for mps but the
truth is that this isn't felt equally
there are some mps who are far more at
risk who face far more abuse there was
an online report by amnesty
international a few years ago for
example that found that diane abbott
received half of all the online abuse
levels at members of parliament so there
are additional measures that are needed
not just about security but just about
support for people to be able to go
about their daily lives about proper
advice there's a huge disparity between
the advice and support that's offered by
different police services around the
country i mean i had an experience of
being um accosted outside parliament a
few years ago during a rally um that it
was about a it was a leave rally around
brexit there was a effigies of sadiq
khan and theresa may being dragged
through the street we were told by
police officers we had to walk through
that rally in order to get into
parliament we were surrounded
and there was very little response and
when i complained to the parliamentary
authorities about it and said there were
people standing there watching this
unfold i was told well unfortunately
people have strong views about brexit
and they're entitled to
to um to to voice them of course i
accept they are but i don't accept that
members of parliament should be blocked
from entering parliament or intimidated
in the course of their daily duties i've
spoken to other members of parliament
who have an amazing response from local
police forces so it's still very patchy
and i think we've got to get away from
this idea that it's about whether you
protect mps or whether you protect
democracy you have to protect mps to be
able to go about their daily business
and be free to speak on behalf of their
constituents if you want to protect
their democracy we've got to get the
balance right
practically
um realistically
i don't think i
managed to get anything very specific
from the home secretary
but
what would you do what um what would you
want to
happen now
that would make
you feel that you could carry out your
democratic uh duties uh in full
confidence that you would be safe
i'm not sure that we could ever get to
that point if i'm honest we've had
stephen timms one of my colleagues was
stabbed a few years ago we had the case
of the mp before that whose case worker
was killed we've had a plot to murder
rosie cooper my neighbouring mp and of
course what happened to joe and now
david i'm not sure
that that moment is recoverable and i
say that with sadness but i think
there's an element of realism about this
mps are well known in our constituencies
people tend to know where we live we're
out and about we're normal human beings
we go out and about on the weekends and
you know go to the local shops
i'm not sure that we can ever eliminate
the risk but i think there are other
things that can be done to reduce the
risk i think the suggestion from the
speaker about ensuring that anyone who
wants or needs security at surgeries is
a good idea not least because people
often know even if we don't advertise
them that they're happening and so they
can become a magnet for people who want
to cause trouble and i think there's
more that we can do about the political
culture you alluded to it in the
interview with pretty patel but i think
we really do all of us in parliament
need to tone down the rhetoric towards
one another especially when that strays
into rhetoric that is dehumanizing
that treats people not as other fellow
human beings or somehow questions
people's motives most people go into
parliament as you've seen with the
outpouring of love for david most people
go into parliament because they want to
make things better we might disagree on
how to do that but we've got to create a
better culture if we want to actually
achieve it where we see quite a lot of
what you've just been talking about is
on social media and the home secretary
seemed to
hold open the possibility
that the
right to anonymity which currently
exists on social media
uh may not be sacrosanct would you
support the idea
that anonymity
uh
be is removed from people who post on
social media platforms
i think the difficulty with removing
anonymity altogether is that you've got
pro-democracy protesters and campaigners
you've got
whistleblowers people around the world
who sometimes have to use some level of
anonymity in order to make themselves
heard
and so the debate that we've been having
in parliament through the online safety
bill is about how you get that balance
right there are limits perhaps that you
can put on anonymous accounts for what
they're able to
do and how they're able to interact with
other people
online and that have to be surely there
has to be repercussions for people
engaging in what would be criminal
behaviour if it happened in person but
doing so online whether they're
anonymous
or otherwise i have to say i listen to
pretty patel talking about online safety
and you know i know that she gets a lot
of abuse on social media as well and i'm
extremely sympathetic but it is a bit
rich for the home secretary to say that
she takes that very seriously when the
government have been dragging their feet
on this legislation for years
and currently we're at a situation where
they're not proposing that there'll be
any penalties for top executives of tech
companies who don't abide by the online
proposed code if there are repeated
breaches of that code if they're not
upholding their responsibilities there
ought to be penalties for that we can't
continue with a situation in which diane
abbott once described as the wild west
where some people are targeted so
severely that it does impact on their
ability to speak out not just mps but
you know young people particularly voice
those concerns as well many of them
driven offline by the amount of hate
that is on there
so on social media you would be open to
some limits on anonymity and also
new penalties for the social media
platforms
yes and we've got to you know as i say
we've got to get the balance right
because social media can be an enormous
force for good i see it very much in the
course of my day job where you've got
some incredible
um campaigners the women of belarus the
pro-democracy protesters in hong kong
the young people of afghanistan they've
managed to use social media in order to
make themselves heard and if you speak
to childline they'll say that social
media has been a major problem for a lot
of young people but it's also been a way
in which young people can now reach out
and get help in a way that they couldn't
when i was a child so we've got to get
the balance right to make sure that we
use this as a force for good in every
era where we've been through
technological revolutions that's always
been the case the one thing i do agree
with pretty patel about is that i really
don't think that we've got to grips with
this yet we haven't worked out how to
manage it so that it works in the
interest of democracy rather than
working against it
lisa nandy thank you very much indeed